-We are back with Will Forte
And, Will,
we have heard your dog.
Your dog has been
chewing on something.
And you also --
Was that your puppy?
-Yes.
We just got a puppy
about six weeks ago.
So it's about 12 weeks old now
Mud Butt.
-So you got Mud Butt
during the pandemic,
which is very kind of you,
because obviously
I think dogs --
Harder finding owners
at a time like this.
-Yes. Yes, we actually found him
on the way up
to our self-isolation,
so we -- Yeah.
-And how is it going so far?
Because, you know,
this isn't the best time maybe
to be house-training a dog
-I feel like it's --
I mean, it is --
It is, to me, I think,
a really good time, because...
-Yeah, I guess you're right.
-...you're gonna be there
always -- You know, we're
training it to get outside now
I've never potty-trained
a dog before.
I've had dogs
when I was growing up.
But we just --
We were horrible dog owners,
and we just kept
the dog outside.
And the dogs would just po
wherever they wanted to.
So this, this --
But it is a full-time job.
I mean, for sure 50% of the time
is cleaning up dog poo or pe
or dog vomit.
-Dog segue, you're in the new --
Is it the film, "The Scoob"?
-Yeah, yeah.
-And you're the voice of Shaggy?
-I'm the voice of Shaggy.
-Can we hear a little Shaggy
-Oh, my God. Uh --
I guess the best thing I can say
is, "Zoinks."
-[ Laughs ]
Very, very, very good.
-"Scoob." You know,
I don't got --
I would try to practice gettin
into character for the voice
every time I'd go in there
And, God,
it would take me forever.
And I wouldn't even know
if I would get in the right --
to the right place,
so, like, being put on the spot.
-You -- I mean, my memory of you
at "SNL," 'cause you didn't --
Not from lack of talent, you
did not do a ton of impressions.
And if you were ever
given an impression,
you would basically
do that voice in the hall
for seven straight days
leading up to the show.
-Well, this is -- You know
it's a -- It's a --
Being put in this position
which is, I mean, it's an hono
to get to do this,
'cause Casey Kasem is --
You know, what an iconic voice
that he created.
And then Matthew Lillard
did a friggin' fantastic job
I thought.
-He really, really did.
-So it was very nerve-racking.
But I've been
in this situation before,
because, you know, like
you said, when I was at "SNL,"
I had to do George W. Bush
after Will Ferrell.
And so it's just --
It's an impossible task.
Like, it's --
I didn't want anybody to d
George Bush after Will Ferrell
And then to...
-Right.
-...be the person
who has to do it is scary.
-Can I put you on the spot her
and ask you to do maybe my
favorite impression of yours
You have a one-word impression
you would do for John McCain
Do you remember that?
-"Friends?"
-Great. Thank you so much.
Really, just as good
as I remembered it.
So, this is true. This is a true
thing that I'm so excited about,
and I was lucky enough
to read a couple of the scripts.
"MacGruber" is going to be
a television show.
Is that -- That is accurate.
-It is. We're --
We are still waiting
for the official green light
But it's looking good.
And we're moving towards it.
We're almost done
writing the series.
It would be an eight-episode
series, yeah.
-So, Will, this was a film
that is a fantastic film,
"MacGruber," that did not,
I think we can say,
make a ton of money
at the box office.
And yet, in the decade since
I'm assuming you, like me,
have heard from so many people
how much they love that film
-It was written off for dead
when it defecated the bed
at the box office.
But then I think people
have given it a second chance.
I hope -- You know,
we were so proud of that movie
that it was tough to take
when it first did so poorly.
But then we thought,
"You know what?
Screw everybody, you know?
We love this thing,
and, you know, we spent a lot of
time on all these dick jokes."
-Yeah. I think they're
some of the smartest dick joke
you'll ever see on film.
And I just --
-Well, because
the jokes are from you.
-Oh, thank you.
But it's a film that I'm always,
with no exception,
when people tell me
they haven't seen it, I --
You know, I'll say, "I promise
whatever your
expectations are for it,
it is so much better than that."
-The movie is not for everybody.
Like 1 out of every 500,00
people maybe like it,
but like it to a nice degree
So with the series, I feel lik
people who like the movie --
Like, if you loved the movie
one out of every five of those
people will love the series.
So we're getting better.
We're getting better with our,
you know --
1 out of every 500,000.
Now it's --
No. We're --
If you liked the movie,
I think you're gonna like
what we're doing.
It's kind of -- About seve
years after the movie ends
is when the series takes up.
And it's pretty fun so far
-I can't wait.
Thank you so much
for making time for us today
I love you so much, will.
Congrats again
on your engagement.
And I will see you soon.
-Stay safe,
and thank you very much.
-Alright. Will Forte, everyone